another victor after a very tense game
is indeed here with us alejandro elshaan
welcome to the studio what a game take
us a little bit through that and tell us
a little bit uh about your feelings of
returning to saint louis and playing
once again over the board chess
well it was a very good feeling winning
the uh first round this is actually now
with this one playing spring classics
i've played all four seasons so this is
the first time for me completed the
seasons so it feels good to be here
playing chess and i haven't played much
in 2020 and nothing in 2020 and very few
games in 2021
so feels great to be here playing one
game a day it's always a great treat and
pleasure being being here and this is
the first time i also win my first round
game so it couldn't be a better start
huh
it feels like that was the reality for
most of us not playing too much just uh
in 2020 and 2021 but uh now we're back
over at the board take us through this
game
sure actually wasn't a very good game
but let's look at it absolutely here it
is up on the board okay
take us to the critical position yeah
c4 e6
uh uh well i didn't expect bishop v7
actually so i was out of my prep because
he always plays almost
exclusively c6 here so
i just when i play bishop e7 relatively
quickly i just thought okay let's play
old school chess so play bishop g5
castle rook c1 so cop of course powerful
stuff
and h6 bishop h4
b6 e3
6 f6 takes cded yes this is goes back
carp of karpov uh spassky match 1973 or
74. semi-final of the world championship
all right
so let's keep going this
and here after this i messed up i think
here i messed up i play knight d2
i think i should go knight d1 because
re-run if he goes f5 i can go f4 later
and put the knight back on e5 you're
much faster yeah yeah that's why i was
worse after i mean i don't know if i
have it right away because he has queen
e7 now but if we do the right
can't go knight d3 f4 and d5 so because
my plane is always bishop on f3 g3
bishop comes under knight d3 then i want
to go back queen c2 before right i mean
you guys are better than me
so
i played actually this plan in two was
roger harshly born in 2005
he was pretty young but he was
definitely born because i'm the oldest
player in that whole tournament
it i am the oldest player so it feels
very
special it's the first time i'm the
oldest player in the whole hall and you
were mentioning that on one of your
posts uh on facebook yeah yeah this is
the first time i am the only one
[Laughter]
so when i play rpmania he i'm three
times his age and i play okay
he's like three times his age
but where's the three times the rating
right yeah
yeah
i need to get that there too so you want
to go back to the game let's go back to
the game okay
so yeah i think now i'm probably screwed
up if you run engine i'm probably
slightly worse here already so i just
tried to just
muster up something g3 this bishop d3
g5 and i was very happy of seeing this
move that was not a good move i was sure
because after this move you want g5 now
queen city doesn't have queen g6 because
of g4 i think he missed you for here
because if i go f4 i would he would play
queen g6 there and then instead of
rookie instead of queen c2 if i play f40
he has queen g6 and now he has he takes
f4 now you don't have a kingpin h1 and
that is a template yes yeah because of
this problem right where you're taking
again it's a pin okay
so
queen c2
and queen e6 then i play a force i
thought okay probably equalized here now
g4 because he has to below g otherwise
knight is coming back the difference of
a tempo right yeah yeah so he has to go
g4 oh is this is bad okay
um can i play a3
actually if i remember correctly uh i
was checking this uh position with the
engine the engine's moves uh was h3
consider that yeah i consider h3 takes
knight f3 right is that i don't remember
what the computer looked g8 and i was i
wasn't sure what to do here because
queen of three takes rook g3 maybe king
two h2 what's the knight f6 uh knight to
f6 is coming with uh tempo knight to g4
oh my goodness i wasn't i was sure takes
f5 no no no sorry he doesn't play right
either way he goes with af8 first and
then knight
queen g6 first
okay
rook g1
yeah uh knight f6 now maybe no but i
still take on f5 and then i g4 king h1
is nothing let me just show this oh yes
no but i can simply also just take on g4
uh
because you know i said there's a nice
line there
i i think maybe too much analyzing this
position because h3 if he goes h5 i know
i don't if i calculate correctly hg now
i have e4 because after all the captures
they'll have a queen h2 at the end oh oh
my god where'd this come from
do i have it can we check with the
engine or something if i have i have an
engine oh you have it does it work i
mean i don't usually use it yeah it
works
you've got the inclusion of the edge
file because now after 94
i have 96 qh2 and you're actually
checkmating so i saw that that that this
must work but then gtx h3 i couldn't
figure out ah
it would have been it felt right but i
couldn't see entirely through it but you
played a5 which felt right as well
because you're trying to expand on the
queen
yeah block that bishop on b7 there's no
more c5 coming yeah if i i mean i was
surprised that i played knight a4 i was
trying to make sure he never played c5
because if he doesn't play c5 i'm okay
it was bad probably it was lots of
temporary one
and then
yeah that was
that was a shocker big shocker and after
bishop b5 then then because shaker was
cd4 i didn't see that one coming at all
well it wasn't a good move
that's what happens here takes on d4 so
he gave up takes and then king after
rookie seven now critical i think bishop
d7 is bad right
uh so explain to us why e8 is not good
can you explain to us why rfe8 is not
good doubling up yeah e8 uh
because v2 is covered now i think on f5
you can just simply take on f3 yeah so
don't take on d7 that would be a
checkmate in one move but you simply
take on f5 yes it's falling apart for
black right yeah i spent 20 minutes 15
minutes here and all my gut feelings was
saying i have to go with ship d3 and i
still played bishop xd7 well to be fair
the engine move is knight c3
so i know don't feel too bad
um yeah bishop d3 just uh to to spare
you uh is not as good as bishop takes d7
ah okay so okay so if those were your
two options you got it right all right
okay so i took on d7
probably i'm somewhat better
uh plus three plus three wow okay so i i
was like it must be winning but it's a
long way but three plus three okay but
this engine i should have taken there
again huh
yeah okay don't worry about those this
is the hard game to those uh question
marks they don't matter too much yeah in
a practical game okay knight b6 through
e7
i will go very fast yeah rookie seven
then i think rocket is a mistake because
he had to go bishop a6 to cover so
rookie eight and then
therefore and then that knight should be
winning now let's see three and then
sorry the queen d3 and then after that i
i don't know if i ever blundered you
want to go fast if you see if i landed
in time pressure oh
didn't see that one made a mistake it's
king g6 i just went to grab material in
time you keep missing many wins huh no
no it just thinks that
you know it's it thinks that plus four
and plus three you know it's not the
strongest engine so it doesn't have the
okay any sophistication so here i
started feeling a little bit worried uh
if a4 is a mistake or not
oh major do i let go of the win or still
winning
do you want the truth i i i felt i felt
i i blundered yeah it doesn't like it it
says it's 0.6 because of
maybe d6 yeah
i i felt it yeah yeah but that's such a
natural move why
why did he play bishop to a7 yeah and
now i was feeling
why is it winning after a5 now yeah it's
completely winning and now once i play
five i was yeah because not b5 b6 is
coming there's no defense against that
and uh
he played okay k1 but now it's more 40
so i simply found knight the fun fight
i'm rerouting and i really like this
move knight f1 and it's just falling
apart it's funny this bishop on a7 is
we're kind of
we love these bishops next to each other
right they seem so powerful but they're
actually both blocked they're not doing
anything yeah exactly that's why i was
surprised with tcd4 because this
structure is really against the bishops
they don't do anything
yeah absolutely you definitely evaluated
this better than your opponent in a
roller coaster a bit of a game but at
the end now when secured also thanks for
joining us thank you for having me in
the studio no of course of course that
was a great
entertaining game
i hope i managed to show up more often
by winning some more games
you got to show those kids
all right also let's take a look
specking of kids of what's going on in